digamos que tenemos la integral
indefinida de 1 sobre un 36 más x xi más
x cuadrada
dx
y bueno como puedes ver esta integral no
es fácil no tengo ahorita una anti
derivada a la mano que a que yo pueda
hacer sustitución y de una manera rápida
también sería deseable tener un 2 x en
algún lugar para hacer sustitución pero
no la tengo así que recurriremos a las
identidades trigonométricas y una manera
de ver esto y de hecho así es como
funciona mi mente es observar que esto
es una constante + x cuadrada pero me
gustaría verlo como uno más algo al
cuadrado y ver qué función
trigonométricas puedo utilizar así que
voy a reescribir esto como la integral
indefinida
voy a poner de x en el numerador sobre
la pintar este sea la integral de de x
que está dividido entre 36 que está
multiplicando a 1 más
x cuadrado entre 36 que es otra forma de
escribir la integral y ahora pensemos en
las identidades trigonométricas en una
que podamos sustituir exactamente aquí y
que de alguna manera no simplifique el
trabajo y la que me viene a la mente es
la que dice que uno más
tangente cuadrado de teta pero
escribirlo
uno más la tangente cuadrada de teta
pero primero quiero desarrollar esto y
la tangente cuadrado de teta la puedo
reescribir como uno más el seno cuadrado
de t está entre el coseno cuadrado de
teta y ahora el 1 es simplemente coseno
cuadrado entre coseno cuadrado de teta
así que voy a reescribir esto como el
coseno cuadrado de theta que está
dividido entre el coseno cuadrado de
teta esto es uno más
el seno cuadrado de teta y seno cuadrado
de teta más coseno cuadrado de teta es
igual a 1 por la definición del círculo
unitario así que esto será uno sobre el
coseno cuadrado de teta y uno sobre el
coseno cuadrado de teta es la secante
cuadrada de teta y si ahora hacemos la
sustitución lo que queremos hacer es que
esta expresión que esté aquí sea igual a
1 + tangente cuadrada de teta esta
expresión será uno más la tangente
cuadrada de teta que finalmente va a ser
la secante cuadrada de teta y va a ser
muy útil
por lo que ahora diremos que x cuadrada
sobre 36 va a ser igual a la tangente
cuadrada de theta si tomamos la raíz
cuadrada de ambos lados nos va a quedar
que x sobre 6 es igual a la tangente de
theta por lo que x es igual a 6 veces la
tangente de teta ahora vamos a tomar la
derivada en ambos lados con respecto a
theta
tenemos de x con respecto a de teta es
igual a pero cuál es la derivada de la
tangente de teta y déjame hacerla para
ti porque no recuerdo bien si lo he
hecho en los vídeos del sitio así que a
ver vamos a hacerla por la causa esto
será 6 veces
la derivada de la tangente de teta con
respecto a de teta que es la que vamos a
encontrar ahorita que entonces será lo
mismo que escribir en la derivada con
respecto a teta de el seno de teta entre
el coseno de teta y esto va a ser igual
a la derivada con respecto a teta de
haber déjame acomodo un poco también te
he comentado que no me acuerdo mucho de
las derivadas de los cocientes así que
lo voy a escribir como el seno de teta
multiplicado por el cose no detecta a la
menos uno y esto a que será igual pues
bueno será igual a la derivada de la
primera función ésta que está aquí que
seno de teta y su derivada de estos seno
de teta ya que como coseno de teta
multiplicado por la segunda expresión si
la que está aquí o sea que es x coseno
de teta la menos uno mira observa que
puse el menos uno entre paréntesis para
no confundirnos con el inverso del cose
no detecta es coseno de teta
y ahora le voy a sumar la derivada de
coseno de tétano más bienes cosenos de
tala menos 1 entonces esto sería menos 1
por coseno de teta al menos 2 tenemos
que hacer la derivada de lo que tenemos
afuera x lo que tenemos adentro ósea es
lo mismo que tener x a la menos 1 que se
deriva como menos una vez x a la menos 2
de crem en tanto el exponente y me falta
multiplicarlo por la derivada de lo que
está dentro que la derivada de coseno de
teta que es menos seno de teta y todo
esto lo voy a multiplicar por seno de
teta esto es la derivada de esto que
tenemos aquí que es todo lo que está en
verde multiplicado por la primera
expresión
sigamos coseno de teta / coseno de teta
esto es igual a 1 y aquí tengo un -1 y
aquí tengo un menos seno de tetas así
que esto me va a quedar en un signo más
y tenemos seno de teta por seno de teta
o sea seno cuadrado de t está dividido
entre coseno cuadrado de teta y esto que
es igual pues a 1
más la tangente cuadrada de teta y uno
más está tangente cuadrado de teta ya
habíamos visto que es la secante
cuadrado de teta
a gusto cuando las cosas empiezan a
simplificarse así que regresemos y
tenemos que esto es igual
la secante cuadrada de teta y si ahora
queremos saber tx a que es igual
entonces de x será seis veces la secante
cuadrada de teta de teta
así es como queda de equis pero en el
futuro vamos a querer regresar y saberlo
en términos de teta quienes teta y esto
es muy simple porque tomaremos la arco
tangente en ambos lados o sea la arco
tangente de x sobre 6 va a ser igual a
teta y vamos a dejar aquí este resultado
veamos cómo quedó nuestra integral ahora
entonces nos queda la integral de de x
pero quién es de x ahora pues es 6
la secante cuadrada de teta de t está
dividido entre lo que está aquí que es
36 veces uno más la tangente cuadrada de
teta
ahora sabemos que esto que está aquí es
igual a la secante cuadrada de theta ya
lo vimos varias veces entonces tenemos
secante cuadrada de teta en el numerador
y en el denominador y entonces este
cancela al que está aquí abajo y por
suerte para nosotros ahora esto lo vamos
a escribir como la integral de 6 sobre
36 es un sexto de de teta o sea que
tenemos un sexto de teta más una
constante
y sustituyendo otra vez utilizando el
resultado que tenemos aquí que teta es
igual al arco tangente de x sobre 6
podemos encontrar que la integral de 1
sobre 36 más x al cuadrado es igual a un
sexto del arco tangente de x sobre 6 más
una constante y con esto hemos terminado